today on the matt walsh show an official
in california votes to ban
outdoor dining and then immediately goes
to eat at a restaurant outdoors we have
gotten used to this sort of hypocrisy
from our rulers but
we should not be used to it so we'll
talk about that today also five
headlines including
controversy over a restaurant owner who
scolded his patrons for twerking in his
restaurant
people are offended you know that he
told them to stop twerking but
reasonable people are more so concerned
that he had to tell them in the first
place and
in our daily cancellation as we get into
the holiday season i will be canceling
christmas trees unfortunately have to do
it all of that and more today
on the matt walsh show
well you know we all like to complain i
know i do in general just in general i
like to complain but if you haven't
noticed but we'd like to complain
especially as conservatives
about the fact that so many companies
out there a lot of the companies that we
let's be honest give our money to
patronize
um are not on our side and are working
against us in the culture
and you know it's one thing to boycott
companies you don't like
that's one thing we could talk about but
one thing i think we could all agree on
is that we should be supporting
companies that support us
and that's especially the case with
charity mobile the pro-life phone
company with charity mobile
five percent of your monthly plan price
goes to the pro-life pro family charity
of your choice
um and that's you know that's sort of
like the headline okay so every time
you're paying your bill you're also
giving to this cause and you know that
you're supporting a company that also
supports the cause
there's a lot of other perks that come
it's it's just a great company in
general great service that new
activations and eligible accounts
get a free cell phone with free
activation and free shipping there's no
contracts no termination fees there's
uh it's a no risk situation with a 30
day guarantee so they're not trying to
get you locked into something you don't
want to be locked into and they've got
live customer service if you need them
based right here in the usa uh and if
you you know if you're a parent and you
want to block
use of cellular data picture messages
text messages whatever you want to do
um you know if your kid has a phone you
could do that as well
and all of that while you are helping to
build a culture of life in america
by supporting a pro-life company and i i
can't emphasize enough this is a win-win
situation when you're getting a great
service
wonderful product also supporting the
most most important cause of all the
pro-life cause
so call charity mobile at 1-877-474-3662
or chat with them online at
charitymobile.com
so we all know how this story goes by
now we've heard a version of it dozens
of times
the latest twist los angeles county
supervisor sheila cole
voted to ban outdoor dining in los
angeles county which would mean shutting
down
tens of thousands of businesses and
putting many of them under permanently
and then promptly right after this vote
went and dined outdoors at a restaurant
here's the fox 11 report from la it says
quote fox 11 received multiple tips that
shortly after her vote on tuesday cole
was seen dining outside at ilforno
trattoria in santa monica an italian
restaurant near her house that she was
previously described as one of her
favorite restaurants when fox 11
investigative reporter bill mulligan
stopped by the restaurant to ask about
cole's visit managers told him
they quote didn't want to get involved
and they have no comment
now just a side note here i understand
that the managers don't want to get
involved
um but they should get involved this
ridiculous
tyrant is trying to destroy your
business she wants to take you down she
wants to impoverish
your children you should have banned her
from the restaurant when she showed up
you should have had security escort her
out out the door
in front of everybody you should have
embarrassed and humiliated her
see one of the aspects of this whole
farce of the lockdowns and everything
that else is going on is the
submissiveness of people
the people who should be standing up for
themselves churches not willing to fight
back against
insane infringements on their first
amendment freedoms business owners not
willing to
defy the orders from psychopaths like
sheila
people obediently wearing masks even
just to walk outside down the street
because that's what they've been told to
do by people who don't wear the masks
themselves
the only way out of this the only way to
stop it the only
end game is for people to refuse to
comply with the dictates and commands
of petty tyrants like sheila just refuse
scoff at her waiver off continue doing
what you want to do
that's the only way as long as we
cooperate as long as we submit it's not
going to end
it will never end all right back to the
article
it says during tuesday's la county board
of supervisors meeting cole
referred to outside dining as a most
dangerous situation
um over what she described as a risk of
tables of unmasked patrons potentially
exposing their servers to the
chronovirus
she says this is a very serious health
emergency and we must take it seriously
the servers are not protected from us
and they're not protected from their
other tables that they're serving at
that particular time
plus all the hours in which they're
working cole went on to vote in support
of restricting outdoor dining in los
angeles county which passed by a three
to two margin
of the board of supervisors cole's visit
to the restaurant came before the
outdoor dining ban took effect wednesday
evening
but her decision is likely to draw
criticism from those who have grown
frustrated with elected officials taking
a hypocritical hypocritical approach
to what they have preached as cold dined
at the restaurant a mere hours
after she said doing such a thing would
be unsafe and would contribute to the
surge in covenant 19 cases
now sheila did provide um a statement to
fox via a spokesperson you could tell me
if you think this is sufficient
does this um is this enough to make you
say okay i'm satisfied she said
this is from the spokesperson says she
did dine at alfresco
did dine alfresco at ilforno on the very
last day it was permissible
she loves ilforno has been saddened to
see it like so many restaurants
suffer from a decline in revenue she ate
there taking appropriate precautions
and sadly will not dine there again
until our public health orders permit
oh she loves it you see she she loves it
but is in the process of demolishing it
she hates to see its decline in revenue
but she is
personally and specifically working to
take away
its revenue you see how that works does
that make sense to you
no it probably doesn't because you're
not a sociopath
in order for there to be this much of a
disconnect between what you say
and what you do and in order to so
casually
decimate the lives of so many millions
for no reason at all
and then to go and enjoy a nice meal
served to you by the very people whose
lives you are in the process of ruining
you must be a sociopath no mentally
healthy person could manage this
and there are a lot of sociopaths ruling
us right now
as we have discovered so a few points
that i want to make here um
in no particular order first is this i
have a modest proposal for
politicians or public health officials
um who violate their own lockdowns or
operate in their personal lives in a
manner inconsistent with their public
fear-mongering
i propose that they'd be dragged into
the town square
tarred and feathered and then loaded
onto a helicopter and sent to gitmo for
30 years
now i'm not advocating vigilante justice
to be clear
i'm calling for actual legislation to be
introduced i want this all done legally
we could call it the
tar and feather hypocritical scumbags
act of 2021
or something that might be a little too
on the nose i don't know
we can brainstorm that part of it the
main point is that people like
sheila should be treated with utter
contempt
and disregard and loathing that's what
she deserves
that's what she would receive in a
healthy republic
other than uh you know besides or
instead of politeness and submissiveness
you know a restaurant politely serving
her
after she just void voted to destroy
them
second point um it's worth reflecting on
another aspect of the problem
namely that the lockdowns and mask
mandates and all the rest of the covid
related initiatives
have empowered dozens hundreds of these
kinds of people all across the country
now we already know about the governors
like cuomo and whitmer who have gone mad
with the power they've been given or
rather have taken
and we know about the incompetent
floundering nitwit mayors like de blasio
and lightfoot
who've also enjoyed play acting as roman
emperors
but the real danger is that we have to
deal with lower level
bureaucrats especially old ones like
sheila who would have loved to have you
know to have
gained real power and maybe be mayors or
senators or governors or something on
that level
but somehow lack the talent and charisma
of even bill de blasio
and so we're stuck for decades as county
supervisors
or town councilmen or whatever now even
those people
have the power to with the swipe of a
pen
lock people in their homes impoverish
them
plunge them into destitution and many
have taken full advantage
see a tyrant is not just a dictator
or like a warlord a tyrant is someone
who gets off on exploiting whatever
power they have and whatever control
they have over other people
there are parents who are tyrants there
are assistant managers at home depot who
are tyrants hell there are there are
customer service reps at the cable
company who are tyrants
they have a little bit of power and
control over you when you call the
company
and they're and they're manning the
phones and they answer and they're going
to use it whatever little power they
have
they're going to use it to make your
life miserable because that makes them
feel better we've all we've all dealt
with people like this
they are tyrants just on the smallest
imaginable scale because that's as far
as they've been able to go
the problem now is that a lot of
low-scale tyrants have been given way
more power
than they were ever supposed to have
they've been given real power over your
life
and now we're all paying the price for
it third final point
and this has been explained many times
and shouldn't need to be explained at
all because i think it's rather obvious
but i will explain it because there are
still many people who are confused on
this point
when we talk about politicians or public
officials
not practicing what they preach when it
comes to covet
we're not playing a game of gotcha okay
that's not the point we're not going for
a ticky tacky hair splitting sort of
thing here the point is that if they
really believe what they say
they wouldn't even be tempted to act in
a way that's inconsistent with what they
say
if they really believed that eating at a
restaurant is a
very dangerous situation they wouldn't
want to do it themselves
you know so when you catch whether gavin
newsom was caught
and he said well you know we all make
mistakes
yeah okay that that excuse might work
in in some scenarios with politicians
who do do one thing and you'll say one
thing do another
when they're making the kinds of
mistakes that normal people would be
tempted to make
but in this case i mean you said it's
dangerous it could kill you why would
you even be tempted to do that if you
really believe it
the fact that they do things that they
have called dangerous and deadly
shows that they don't believe that those
things are dangerous and deadly
obviously
they are passing these laws and
ordinances and regulations
and decimating the economy and
destroying lives on a basis
and using a logic that they do not
believe
which means they aren't doing it for the
reasons they give because again
they don't believe those reasons they're
doing it for some other reason
and our point when we bring up the
hypocrisy is simply to ask
what's the real reason sheila
doesn't want to doesn't want to shut
down outdoor dining because she thinks
it's dangerous
she doesn't think it's dangerous clearly
so
why is she really shutting it down
that's our point that's our question
it's a good question
and the answer to the question seems
clear and has already been alluded to
she's doing it for power and control
that's why they're all doing it
it's what all of this is about it has
always been about
and it's time that the american public
finally wake up to that fact
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
so uh we'll start with this from the
daily wire and kind of we were just
talking about
you know people cooperating with um with
with these mandates when they shouldn't
be this has especially been the case
with churches
and it says police blocked congregants
from attending a drive-in church service
at a church in rural
manitoba canada on sunday morning as
depicted in a facebook video which will
play for you in a second police blocked
cars from entering the parking lot
of the church of god steinbach forcing
them to line up on the adjacent street
to listen to senior pastor heinrich
hildebrand preach from over a
loudspeaker
um hildebrand preached god has given us
the right to worship him together and he
wants to see his people united
it seems like we're living in a
different canada it's very heartbreaking
to be the church of god at steinbeck
which is about 40 miles southeast of
winnipeg
was fined five thousand dollars last
week for holding services and defiance
of what hildebrand describes as
draconian and unconstitutional orders
so there's a facebook live stream that
one of the congregants
recorded and um showing the police
presence and
and how how they were how the
congregants were forced to
line up on the street to listen and
we'll play a little bit of that for
right now watch this good morning
thank you for joining us this morning as
you can see the police have decided to
not allow us to have service this
morning
we have speakers set up and are playing
songs
i'm not sure if you can hear me it's
quite loud right here just showing you
what's going on
police have showed up in droves to
decide that
they're not going to let us have service
this morning
in glorious and free canada can you
believe it
look at this look at this
we've got media we've got police on site
lots and lots of police here today yeah
that's uh if
you couldn't see the video there i mean
the it's just an absurd spectacle
where they they were lit the cars are
lined up on the street
and you've got the pastor in the parking
lot shouting to them
through a loudspeaker because they
weren't allowed to go into the parking
lot just for a drive-in service
you know if you've been to a drive-in
service it's just you're in your car in
a parking lot
how could you possibly be spreading a
virus
but even that was not allowed now this
church though okay here here at this
church in canada
this is a good example of the opposite
of what i was talking about before
okay there are a lot of people
submissively going along with it a lot
of church but
here here's a church that's not they've
already they've already been fined and
they're still going forward and doing
whatever they can
um to still meet and worship and pray
together
but so many churches across america
canada across the west
uh the government showed up and said oh
you know you're not we're not
we're not going to let you we tell you
what we've just decided to take your
first amendment rights away
we've decided that you're not essential
anymore and because we've called you
that's the um the back door apparently
that we're allowed to to to exploit in
order to take your first amendment
rights away is all we can do is you know
okay we could take your first amendment
rights away but first we just have to
declare you non-essential and as soon as
we do that
you no longer get um get first amendment
rights now
even though as far as i'm aware in the
first amendment it doesn't say anything
about
this only applies to people the
government deems essential
this goes for everybody
but for so many churches the government
came and said that
and uh they said okay if you say so
and they went home pastors bishops
leaders of the church and now here we
are
you know begging for the courts to bail
us out
and maybe they will the supreme court
had the case up in new york
found that those uh that new york didn't
have didn't have the uh didn't have the
authority
to shut down the churches like it had
and that that's good
but what a pitiful sight it is that we
as
christians in a free country with the
first amendment
this is what we're reduced to sitting
here and just begging supreme court
please bail us out
what should happen from the very
beginning is that the government says oh
you're not essential you can't you can't
gather you can't exercise your first
amendment rights
and what should happen is everyone
listens to that and says oh is that your
opinion okay
well good thanks for sharing and then
you just go to church and continue on
what you're doing
completely ignoring it
if they want to go in arrest everybody
cart the
little old ladies out of church put them
in jail they can do that
if that's the level they want to take
this to
we didn't even try to call their bluff
let's go here number two article from
eater.com says over the weekend
dallas newcomer true kitchen and
cocktails
as a restaurant was at the center of a
social media firestorm
after video of the restaurant
restaurant's owner ranting about the
ills of torquing
went viral on social media the video
posted to twitter by user uh
doesn't matter the user's name depicts a
person looks a whole lot like true
kitchen owner kevin kelly
throwing a massive fit over a group of
women this is i'm reading from the
article this is obviously there's a lot
of editorializing in the way
in the tone of this article throwing a
quote massive fit
over a group of women who were
reportedly twerking to the music played
by the restaurant's dj
according to one source the song that
spurred the incident was
dallas rapper lil rohney
mother f's circle that's the name of the
rapper i think lil roney mother f's
i'm sure his music is um
is is very worthwhile listening to
uh someone says in part all well instead
of quoting him i think we'll just play
the video for you so this was uploaded
to twitter
and it was trending on twitter yesterday
a lot of people very upset with what i'm
about to play for you
uh media writing articles about it you
know
almost unanimously panning this guy for
what he said to the restaurant patrons
who were twerking and uh here it is
listen i invested a lot of money
into buying this building and to
developing this concept so black people
can have somewhere nice to go to okay
somewhere where we can feel good about
ourselves and i think the one
it's not to me to please somewhere where
our people can feel good about ourselves
as a culture okay no no real talk
and so all this twerking is taking the
prime taking the pink
don't bring it here because we're a
restaurant and so beyond that
75 percent of our customers are ladies
and i'm not meaning to show respect for
themselves for how they carry themselves
here so how can i tell the men to
respect themselves
and you guys are talking on glasses if
you want to do it get out my restaurant
because i did it for our people and i
did it for our culture so don't do it
now don't do it again i don't want to
hear if you don't like it get out
because i don't need your money i need
to
provide something for my people and
don't do it again thank you
so that's what people were upset about
now i hear that as a relatively normal
person
i hear that and i think that guy's
awesome let's give him the nobel peace
prize
that's the greatest thing i i love every
bit of that
the only issue i have with what he said
is that he had to say it
there were people apparently as you
heard there in the clip standing on the
furniture at a restaurant
putting their hands on the glass on the
window i guess and twerking
and it's controversial for the
restaurant owner to tell them to stop
you know we have reached peak
entitlement okay we have reached peak
entitled
society when an expectation of the most
basic civilized behavior is considered
over the top
it's not just controversial it's not
just that we're we're having a debate
about
i don't know should should restaurant
managers tell people to stop talking in
the restaurant no it's just
it for a lot of people it's it's for
them it's self-evident that this is way
over the top whoa
what are you doing tell them not to not
to twerk
what is this the 1950s
the expectation here again is just
is is simply don't stand on the
furniture so really it's two things
um don't stand on the furniture i have
to and i admit i have to tell my own
kids that part of it though
we're at a restaurant they're running
all over the furniture tell them don't
don't
it's not a jungle gym so don't stand
on the furniture and don't twerk and
especially don't do both of those things
at a restaurant there are places
unfortunately in society where you can
go and do those things
just not here at a restaurant where
people are trying to eat
it is the lowest possible bar
but these girls apparently i mean these
are the kinds of girls who they see
a really low bar and they think it's a
stripper bowl
now one of the excuses now i'm not
making this up okay
because i i did dive into the um
into the abyss a little bit uh of this
on twitter
and reading some of the reactions and
the the one excuse that kept coming up
over and over again
is that um really this is the restaurant
owner's fault
because his his he was playing music
like he was playing club music
he was playing music that you would find
here in a club and so it's his fault
if you want people twerking in your
restaurant that don't play that kind of
music
as if so you hear a certain song
and that gives you the right and
permission to just twerk matter where
you are
like if you're in a funeral procession
and someone drives by and they're
playing that's not you just start
twerking at the funeral
hey hey i heard the song what do you
want me to do
um and then people also took issue with
uh with not just that he was telling
telling the patrons not to twerk
but that he you know said that women are
disrespecting themselves by behaving
this way
and degrading themselves and of course
these days you can't say that
no no no but he's exactly right
obviously
um as a woman
you know really twerking in general you
are disrespecting yourself uh
making an absolute fool of yourself
degrading yourself
doing it in public at a restaurant even
more so
i just want to be clear about one thing
here just just so you know
and i i think all the women who watch
this show you don't need to hear this
but in case this clip ends up on media
matters and gets shared then maybe
someone would
that needs to hear it will hear it um
if you are a woman behaving this way
you're going to find that a lot of men
support it
there's gonna be a lot of there's
there's a lot of supportive men
you want to go out in public and twerk
and act like a stripper
uh any whoreish behavior there's a lot
of men very supportive of the horse
behavior
the reason for that in every single case
all of those men who are very supportive
of you behaving in this in this way they
support it because they don't respect
you
at all they have no respect for you as a
person
that's why they support it
so if that's what you want if you want
to be not respected
at all then continue right along
this and i that's just the one thing we
need to be clear about
it they they don't support it because
they respect you and they respect your
autonomy
no no no the exact opposite
is the case right number three greta
thunberg
child prophet um tweeted this last week
i just saw this she
tweeted school strike week 119
today is black friday over consumption
is wrecking present and future living
conditions and the planet itself
don't buy stuff you don't need
now i saw this a couple things came to
mind number one a school strike
like that's that's what we need we need
to ever the kids are on a school strike
not by their own choice i don't i don't
think i think i think it's a little bit
a bit redundant to have a school strike
at this point
uh when kids haven't gone to school in
like six months
but the second thing is this you've got
this kid saying don't buy
stuff you you don't need um obviously
nobody asked you
we don't need you know it's we don't
need your permission to buy stuff
um but it does bring to mind for me a
real problem here that
sometimes from the socialists and the
marxists in the far left radicals and
everything
you hear this this message about over
consumption and consumerism
and you know don't run out and buy a
bunch of stuff you don't need
that part of it i agree with them
they're right you shouldn't buy stuff
you don't need
like there's a there's a real criticism
an important criticism
of consumerism that could be made
and that's that is an important
conversation that we could have
because you've got capitalism free
market capitalism
people can do what they want with their
own money they can start businesses
you know pursue the american dream that
sort of thing so you've got that
and it's possible to support that while
not supporting
consumerist culture where the entire
society depends on
and runs on people going out and
spending more than they have
living beyond their means buying a bunch
of junk and filling their house with it
we live in a consumerist culture a
capitalist culture doesn't have to be
consumerist
ours is and so we could
we could uh we could have a real
conversation about that but the problem
is
that the socialists they go from there
and they go all the way to
therefore the government should be in
control of the means of production and
everything else
and so this this discussion about
consumerism unfortunately we can't have
because of the socialists
uh number four this is from the daily
wire it says the star
studded this shocking report here you're
not gonna believe this
star-studded hollywood charity time's up
you know that's the meet the me too
charity time's up
founded after dozens of women came
forward to speak up about sexual
harassment
sexual abuse and even sexual assault
raised more than
three million dollars last year
according to a new york post report
but spent most of that on you guessed it
salaries uh not helping the victims at
all uh it says
time's up has plenty of a-list backers
ranging from media mogul oprah winfrey
to hollywood social justice elites like
brie larson
rhys witherspoon amy schumer um
but it says as we get to the new york
post reports
the organization which is comprised of
the time's up foundation and time's up
now incorporated raised
3 million about 3.6 million dollars in
2018
its founding year but spent 1.4 million
on salaries and only 312
000 on the time's up legal defense fund
for people who have experienced sexual
harassment
altogether time's up spent nearly 40
percent of its income
on salaries another additional 150 000
went to conferences and retreats
um so even the even of the the the
little bit of money that actually went
ostensibly towards
the goal of the organization a lot of
that was was squandered as well
on on nonsense and you know this brings
that brings to mind
the whole thing about how every movement
event eventually becomes a racket
um the only difference is that with the
metoo movement
it was always a racket like it it never
had that time of being a sincere
useful thing it was always a racket from
the very beginning five finally a
headline from new york post it says
kazakhstani bodybuilder marries a sex
doll after a whirlwind romance
says proving that love is blind and
sometimes kooky a bodybuilder from
kazakhstan has tied the knot with his
dearly beloved a sex doll he dated for
eight months before proposing a year ago
there is a video of their of their
nuptials which
i'm not going to play just on the
principle of it but it says clad
in a black tux and bow tie yuri telochko
is seen planting a gentle kiss on margot
who appears a bit stiff in her revealing
white gown
as she clutches a bouquet of flowers and
stares into the distance
and uh and this article's so stupid i
can't continue to read it but they did
have a wedding
ceremony and somehow family members and
friends actually showed up for the
wedding ceremony with the sex doll you
know
i think it's pretty obvious that
something like this was sort of a
publicity stunt
i i think mostly a joke
a really weird joke that you've invested
way too much time and money in
i think that's mostly what it is i i i
hope i'm i'm
i'm assuming but there is a a very real
thing underneath all this a real
cultural phenomenon of people giving up
on
relationships and we see that you know
with the millennial generation many of
them not getting married
just giving up on it now most of them
aren't running out and buying sex dolls
uh rather than replacing human
relationships with sex dolls and
marrying sex dolls instead they you know
have pornography and pornhub and that
sort of thing
but that is a very real uh problem in
our society
people giving up on relationships and
you know maybe down the line
as sex dolls and sex robots become more
uh technologically advanced you know
this this is this is uh
this may be this may be the one thing in
the sci-fi movies you know there's a lot
of things in the sci-fi movies that
haven't happened
we all thought we'd be in flying cars by
now and have hoverboards and everything
that's not happening the one thing
though people running off and marrying
sex robots
yeah probably i could see that happening
we are well on our way
before we get to our daily cancellation
you know a big problem uh for men in
general is that we we don't like going
to the doctor a lot of times you're
embarrassed to go to the doctor
and that can be a real problem because
there could be serious problems you
could get fixed you might not even know
about if you don't go to the doctor
uh and that's why i want to tell you
about new sponsors of the show
for hymns.com fort hymns.com all about
men's wellness
if you need help with ed hair loss you
have a cold
if you're interested in mental health or
cover 19 home tests whatever it is
hymns is here for you through hymns you
can get the prescription medication that
treats e.d
it's real science real solutions for ed
and hims makes all this very easy
um easy easy to do hims connects you
with a licensed medical professional
online who can prescribe
fda approved prescription medication to
treat ed
you get the same active ingredient as
that expensive little pill but without
the expensive price tag on top of it so
you're doing it online you're also
you're also you're not you're not
you're not spending an arm and a leg
this could cost hundreds of bucks
uh if you had to go through a doctor or
pharmacy not so with him hims makes it
simple and affordable
there's no embarrassing conversations no
expensive appointments you just answer a
few questions online about your medical
history
and a provider will confidentially
review it
and so you know for for anyone who
doesn't like going to doctor whatever
the reason is
this is especially great for hims.com
if you you know you don't have to search
online for answers anymore just go to
for hims.com
try hims today by starting out with a
free online visit go to for hims.com
matt for your free visit that's for
hymns.com
i m f-o-r-h-i-m-s dot com slash matt
prescription products are subject to
medical
provider approval and required online
consultation with a medical provider who
will determine if a prescription is
appropriate you can see the website for
details and safety information remember
that's
for hims.com matt well if you're not
already a daily wire member now is the
time to to join because we've got
amazing stuff we've been telling you
about that's right around the corner uh
starting you know in the new year but
even before the new year starting this
friday december 4th
the michael knoll show is going five
days a week with more content for our
members to enjoy
we're adding the entire prageru catalog
to dailywire.com by the end of the year
we've already uploaded all of prageru's
five-minute videos
um the candace owen show from prageru
and michael knowles book club
so all that is there more to come and
you become a member you're going to get
be able to take advantage of that early
next year candace owens is also joining
the daily wire here in nashville
where she'll be launching a brand new
daily wire show in front of a live
studio audience
we're building a new investigative
journalism team we've got feature films
coming out we're doing a lot of stuff
and all of this means you can go outside
the narrative and come over to
dailywire.com
subscribe one other thing if you haven't
already
ordered them you could check out our
daily wire christmas ornaments
uh all of us daily wire hosts plus god
king jeremy boring
are santa's adorable elves made out of
painted
metal i'm being forced to tell you about
this it's on the sheet of paper
um but it would not be my here's
here's all i'll say i was converted
into an adorable christmas elf and made
into an ornament to hang
on christmas tree against my without my
approval
i did not consent to this okay i did not
consent to being
an adorable christmas elf at no point
did anyone call me up
or they could even come into the studio
and say hey do you want to be an
adorable christmas health
we're making these ornaments you want to
be one if they'd asked me i would have
said a no
thanks for asking no
so just know when you buy these
ornaments you are buying them and
putting me on your tree
against my consent
but you can text christmas to eight
three four zero zero to get your tree
decorated
they're going fast so get yours now
that's christmas
to eight three four zero zero and uh on
that note let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
now today for our daily cancellation now
that christmas season has
officially or rather unofficially begun
officially the christmas season actually
starts
on christmas i don't know if you knew
that i'm going to take a bold
bold step that will only shock and
offend you until you realize that i come
not as your oppressor but as your
liberator i seek to free you and free
all of us once and for all
from the tyranny of christmas trees
christmas trees are canceled
this madness has gone on for long enough
i'm drawing the line in the sand right
now
no more christmas trees we are done with
christmas trees
now it may come as a surprise but the
early christians
never thought to cut down a tree and put
it in their house
for three weeks as part of their
christmas celebration
one could only imagine how the
conversation would have went had anyone
suggested something like that
hey it's almost christmas what do you
say we go and chop down that perfectly
healthy tree out there drag it inside
and watch it slowly die
it'll be so festive the idea probably
would not have been warmly received
and that's why nobody had a christmas
tree until some depraved lunatic in
germany
as always in the 19th century decided
that there weren't enough distracting
hassles associated with the holiday
and came up with this idea and it was
the worst thing
anyone had done related to christmas
since saint nick started the whole
gift-giving thing
which is another problem in of itself
now admittedly
this history of christmas and its
traditions may not be entirely
technically accurate but that's not the
point
the point is that we are all burdening
ourselves
with this demented custom for no reason
so there are of course two ways to
approach the problem of obtaining
transporting and erecting
a tree inside your living room this
again is a problem of our own making
it's like if we're all stressed out
about how to capture a squirrel from the
forest
and train it to do jumping jacks the
most stress-free way of doing that
is to not do it because it's bizarre and
pointless
and there are a million better ways to
spend your time but as far as trees go
you have two options right you can go
out and buy a real tree
or you can purchase an imposter a fake
tree an avatar of a tree
the problem with the fake tree is that
it's a fake tree
it's expensive and clunky it doesn't
actually look anything like a real tree
much less does it smell like one so it's
always awkward when you go to someone's
house
and they have a fake tree and they go
doesn't it look real
no it doesn't have you ever seen a real
tree they're outside you should go check
them out
because this doesn't look anything like
it
see whatever joy there is to be gained
from a christmas tree you aren't going
to get it from a fake one
a family with a fake tree has given up
they are just checking the tree box
trying to slide by on a technicality
you might as well put a deflated
basketball on your porch at halloween
instead of a pumpkin
the stand-in is significantly more
depressing
than just not having it at all so that
doesn't work but the real tree is worse
because first of all it's going to run
you upwards of 75 these days 75
for a hunk of lumber that will be
decaying in a heap on your front lawn in
less than a month
you could buy a bottle of blanton's
single barrel bourbon
elijah craig barrel proof even for that
price and it will make you far
jollier than any christmas tree ever
will i assure you
so after you've been basically stripped
naked and robbed by the christmas tree
salesman
you schlepped the thing back to your
house you're dragging inside pine
needles falling and dispersing
themselves into areas of the house that
you won't notice until sometime after
memorial day that begins the process of
somehow
getting this whole entire actual tree to
stand up straight in your house with
nothing but a plastic tree stand and a
couple of screws keeping it in place
if you do get it the same place it'll
inevitably be knocked over multiple
times by the dog the cat your kids
people and pets getting practically
crushed to death left and right
meanwhile the thing requires about 19
gallons of water a day just to keep it
alive and barely so
now you have a half dead dried out chunk
of wood in your house
with electrical wires draped around it
maybe next we can develop an easter
tradition where everybody jumps into a
pool and plays catch with a toaster
plugged into an extension cord
and then what happens as soon as
christmas is over it's like waking up
with a hangover you look at that thing
and
all of the joy and spirit is sucked out
of it
now you see it for the giant pile of
sticks that it always was
and you just want it out of your house
literally the day after christmas you're
looking at your tree with disgust
everybody does
or if you have a fake tree you just put
off the hassle of taking it down
for months until you finally get around
to it only because
you don't want people judging you when
they come over for your fourth of july
barbecue
so the whole thing is madness and it
must end we must free ourselves
we must stand up with one voice and
refuse to be enslaved to this lunacy
it's gone on for too long it ends today
christmas trees are canceled once and
for all
and that's gonna do it for me my wife
wants to go get a christmas treat today
so we're gonna go do that
speaking of not practicing what you
preach
have a great day everybody godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20. a young
woman makes history as the first female
college football player
an la health official calls the refusal
to wear masks domestic terrorism
and the trump team presents more
evidence of election fraud in arizona
check it out on the michael knowles show